c'est une première pour la commune de
trappes qui voit une liste lutte
ouvrière se présenter aux élections
municipales
mené par patrick planque la liste
organisé une réunion publique dans la
salle pablo picasso et une partie des
gens qui sont surpris une partie des
gens qui sont très contents et puis une
partie des gens qui disent c'est très
bien parce que c'est très bien parce que
effectivement faire en temps de ce camp
défendre ce point de vue que les
travailleurs doivent s'organiser se
défendre eh ben ça fait longtemps qu'on
l'a pas entendu pour patrick planque
l'objectif est de faire entendre la voix
des travailleurs pendant ces élections
après la période de grève qui avait
commencé en décembre 2019
on a l'habitude de dire que ce sera une
liste de combat mais effectivement ça
sera une liste pour organiser les luttes
organiser les lutte nécessaire contre
les bailleurs contre les grands
employeurs contre les licencieurs etc et
des élus municipaux ben ça serait un
relais pour défendre ce point de vue là
au sein des entreprises au sein de la
municipalité baisser le taux de chômage
donner le droit de vote trappistes qui
n'ont pas la nationalité et renforcer
les liens sociaux ainsi que la
solidarité sont les points essentiels
pour patrick planque
si réellement dans la population de
trappes on avait
tous les sales tous les gens qui ont
aujourd'hui qui vivent ici qui payent
des impôts mais qui n'ont pas le droit
de vote
parce qu'ils n'ont pas la bonne
nationalité si on avait eu le droit de
les mettre sur la liste pour voter aux
élections municipales comme la gauche
l'avait proposé il ya 40 ans ben c'est
pas une liste de combat qu'on aurait
fait ces dix listes de combat le
candidat sera dimanche 15 mars
face aux quatre autres listes dans la
commune de trappes